okay let's go to the 908 area code 908
span hanging on for a while 908 go ahead
what's your question yes hi I'm just
calling because I was wondering how can
we remain optimistic in the face of all
this political turmoil mm-hmm
hallucinogenics primarily no listen here
here's the this I I don't know the
answer and if you saw the Hat should the
David Pakman show end clip last Monday
you're probably aware that I'm not
particularly optimistic in a lot of ways
but real quickly thinking about it more
political activism than we've seen in a
very long time catalyzed by the presence
of Donald Trump in the White House
possible invigoration of left-wing
voters in red states very good numbers
in terms of Democratic primary turnout
in Texas Alabama special election sort
of a special case but it's all there's
lots of underlying factors that could
make us cautiously optimistic about 2018
and 2020 but the real test will be will
the Left vote this November that's where
I'm really going to either be inspired
by the activism that the two years of
Trump by then will have caused or
incredibly depressed by the lack of it
or likewise thank you all right thank
you so much and on that note calls have
to end they can't go on forever I know
that there are people holding and I
apologize we didn't get to you today but
next time next time we will take calls
again thanks to everybody who called in
oh I think I just got kicked off our own
phone system let's take a break on that
note